hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar the regulation of
alc1 by trim 33 during the dna damage
response
i am jennifer woods of labrutz and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar as a
part of the cell culture heroes series
is presented by lab roots and brought to
you by gibco by thermo fisher scientific
to learn more about the cell culture
heroes webinar series or stay connected
on the latest event sponsored by gibco
please visit the resources tab
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window
at the bottom of your screen to obtain
your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
rukia henry phd candidate rutgers
university in new brunswick
rupia you may now begin your
presentation
good morning everyone and thank you so
much for that introduction i am really
excited to be the gift coastal culture
hero for the month of june
and i am excited to present today's
presentation that is entitled the
regulation of elk one by trim 33 during
the dna damage response and for the
introduction i'm rupiah henry once more
and i'm a phd candidate at rutgers
university and i work on the supervision
of dr sridhar gennison at the cancer
institute of new jersey
so before i go into today's presentation
i would just like to take a minute to
tell you all a little about me
and so
i was actually born
in guyana and i come from a small town
called linden known as the mining title
of linden where i grew up and i have
lived here until i was 17 years old and
so i attended
primary and secondary school or high
school as it's known in guyana
and a fun fact guyana is the only
english-speaking country in south
america and as you can see it is
actually near venezuela and brazil just
for some context guyana is also part of
the caribbean so i'm not only south
americans i'm also caribbean as well
now
while i was living in guyana i always
knew that i wanted to pursue higher
education and so i was determined to be
able to come to the us where i would be
able to obtain that and so in 2014 i
attended howard university where i
pursued my bachelor's of science degree
in biology
and while at harvard university i was
involved in different undergraduate
research projects
um one of my research focused while at
howard looked at mapping the anatomical
locations
of hiv replication in the pediatric
brain
furthermore one summer i interned at
princeton university and i studied the
pathogenesis of herpes viral infection
in the central nervous system so most of
my undergraduate research experience has
been
in neurovirology
and so
how did a neurovirologist in training
end up doing cancer research
so unfortunately my mother was diagnosed
with breast cancer
and as i on my own was doing literature
review to see different treatments that
were available for her metastatic
diagnosis
i realized that the field of cancer
research was ever still in evolving and
that there was still room for new and
better innovative treatment specifically
targeted treatments
and so with that in mind i decided to
attend graduate school where i can be
able to conduct cancer research on my
own
and so
i applied and i accepted
the invitation to attend rutgers
university primarily because this would
have given me the opportunity to conduct
research at the rutgers cancer institute
of new jersey and this
was a great opportunity
as i was able to join the lab of dr
sridhar gennison at the cancer institute
of new jersey and he is the associate
director for translational science
and i also work under the close
supervision of dr atul colcherny who is
a research teaching specialist
and so
the ganeshan lab predominantly studies
dna repair defects in cancer and it's
primarily
interested in looking at if these
effects can be exploited to develop
novel effective and innovative treatment
for breast cancer
and so
today's presentation
will
show you
a project that looked at the dna damage
response and also proteins involved in
dna repair
and this project was spearheaded by dr
atul kulkerny under whose supervision in
the lab i work with
and so for the learning objective of
today's presentation i am interested in
helping everyone understand the
mechanisms of dna damage and repair
how the part dependent dna damage
response pathway is regulated and
finally understanding how key proteins
involved in the dna damage response
including trim33 and alk-1 can serve as
actionable targets in the treatment of
certain cancers
and so
how does our dna become damaged and when
it does how does our cells repair this
damaged dna
and so we can have single-stranded dna
damage
or we can have double-stranded dna
damage and depending on which of these
occurs our cells employ varying
mechanisms that would repair that damage
and so for single stranded dna damage
these can include
repairs such as base excision repair if
there is a single damaged nucleotide we
also have nucleotide excision repair and
this is involved in removing bulky
addicts from our dna
furthermore while our cells are
undergoing dna replication there can be
errors where our bases can become
mismatched and so our cells would
therefore need to employ mismatch repair
in order to excise and synthesize the
correct dna strand and repair it
furthermore
with double-stranded dna breaks our
cells usually employ two pathways the
non-homologous and joining pathway
and the homologous recombination repair
and with all of these different
forms of repair that our cells employ
there are particularly important
proteins that can help to facilitate
this effective repair of our dna
and so today
i will be trying to explain to you some
of the main proteins that can regulate
the dna damage response in ourselves
one of the main important proteins that
we study in the genesis in the genesis
lab is the poly adp ribose
polymerase or parp
protein and this is an important dna
repair factor that is involved in the
dna damage response
and so
in our normal cells tarp is usually at
our chromatin
now with the induction of dna damage
what we have is that parp1 becomes
activated and the activation of parp1 at
sites of dna breaks
causes the formation of what is known as
par chains
and so these polyadp ribose chains
essentially serve as a scaffold to
recruit other important proteins
involved in the dna damage response such
as we can see here apls and l1 and so
think about parp as
the
important protein that is able to
recruit all of the other different
proteins that are responsible for dna
repair so if you have for say a building
under construction you would usually see
scaffolds being built that will allow
multiple workers to work on that
building at once so part and par
function in that same way
and so
one of the main projects in the ganesha
lab looked at the tripartite motif
containing 33 or trim 33 and we found
that this protein functions in the
polyadp-ribose polymerase or
part-dependent dna damage response
through the interaction with amplified
and liver cancer one protein and so
today's presentation will be following
this work that was spare headed by dr
atul kulkerny that i introduced earlier
and so what is trimmed 3 and out 1
before we progress
and so the tripartite motif containing
33 or trim 33 is a nuclear protein
involved in chromatin regulation and
signaling
it contains a ring domain
2b boxes and a plant homeo domain
a bromo domain at the c terminus as well
that we see here
now trim 33 acts as the e3 ubiquitin
ligase and it promotes match for
ubiquitination
nuclear exclusions and degradation via
the ubiquitin proteasol pathway
it interacts with alph one
which is a chromatin remodeler and
removes it from site of dna damage after
dna repair has been initiated and
today's presentation will show you how
we were able to delineate this
conclusion
now alkaline specifically is a
chromodomain helicase dna binding
protein one like that is known as the
amplified and liver cancer one and it is
a member of the snf2 super family of atp
aces that carry a macro domain that
binds to the polyadp ribose or the par
chains at sites of dna damage
and
functions as a chromosome remodeling
enzyme that is able to relax the
chromatin so that other important
repair factors can come in at the site
of dna damage and initiate dna repair
and so
what we knew was that previous studies
have shown that alk-1 is rapidly
recruited to sites of dna damage via its
macro domain
dependent binding with par and the
retention of alk1 on damaged chromatin
is extremely short-lived
and so
this arachnid association and
dissociation of outbound from damaged
sites would imply to us that its
chromatin association is strictly
controlled and regulated
and so in order to gain insight into the
regulation of alk1 during dna damage
response
our lab sought to identify proteins that
might interact with l1 upon dna damage
and so what we see here is the result
from an experiment where hex293 control
cells
and hex293 cells expressing a flag
tagged well-typed out one were either
mock treated or treated with bleomycin
and subjected to immunoprecipitation
using flag beats
and the immunoprecipitates were then
analyzed by liquid chromatography mass
spec analysis to identify potential
interacting proteins with alk1
and so what was observed was that
in agreement with previous reports
peptides for part 1
apls
h2b
the q proteins q70 and q80 and dna pks
which are known to be involved in dna
repair
were thought
to be associating without one
now what was interesting
was that peptides for trim33 were also
found in these outbound
immunoprecipitates
however
what is important to note was that this
was only observed and the bleomycin
treated samples
and this observation
raised the possibility
that
trim 33 potentially interacts without
one
and so to confirm these findings
hela cells were then mock treated or
treated with 300 micromolars of
gliomycin for one hour and then
subjected to immunoprecipitation
using antibody against the endogenous
expression of trim 33 and what we see to
the right is the result of the western
blood analysis
that shows in fact
alk1 is found in the trim-33
immunoprecipitates
only after induction of dna damage
with bleomycin
and hydro
anhydroxyurea indicating that trim 33
and alpha indeed interact in a dna
dependent manner
and so
furthermore
we were now interested in examining
the localization of trim33 to site of
dna breaks
in vitro and so before i go ahead and
show the results from other experiments
that use immunofluorescence
i wanted to explain one of the important
experimental procedures that we employ
in the ganeshan lab that helps us to
study dna damage and visualize the
damage after
and so on day one what we would do is we
would play our cancer cells in a chamber
slide we would leave them to grow
overnight and then on day two
we would transfect them with our plasmid
of interest and so if we would like to
identify or observe the dynamics of trim
33
we can transfect with a trim 33 plasmid
that also contains a gsb construct
and on this same day we will also treat
ourselves with iodo
deoxyuria that will also help to
sensitize our cells to dna damage
now
on day three what we do is we induce dna
damage using uv laser scissors
and on white continuing exposure to
agents such as bleomycin
that can induce ongoing dna damage laser
scissors induce an acute transient dna
damage at very defined time points
making it really amendable to high
resolution time course analysis
and so once we have induced that damage
if we're looking at varying time points
to see the recruitment or dynamics of
proteins involved in dna damage we will
fix those cells and then we will stain
with phosphoh2ax antibody and gamma h2ax
is a common marker that is used in dna
damage because it indicates to us that
dna damage has indeed occurred
then once we have done that
we can visualize under a fluorescence
microscope to observe our protein of
interest
and so
i also would like to explain some of the
trim 33 mutant constructs that we might
use to transfect ourselves with and so
this shows
a wild type schematic of trim 33
including all of its functional domains
including the rings domain the b boxes
domain and also the phd and bromo domain
furthermore
we also have mutants with a ring domain
mutant trim 33 ca labeled here
we also have
this ring domain with two cysteines
alanine mutants at amino acids 125 and
128 deleted
furthermore we have another trim 33
mutants with the internal dilution of
the histone binding phd domain or the
bromo domain as well
furthermore there is the mutant form of
trim33 with the atpase domain mutated as
seen
here and so
in order for us to
examine the localization of trim-33 at
sites of dna breaks
we treated our gila cells
with
idu and then we subjected them to uv
laser scissors
and what we can see on the right
is the results
showing that
about five minutes post dna damage with
the uv laser scissors we see the dynamic
recruitment of trim 33 at these brake
sites
it is sustained and observed about 10 to
15 minutes but then at 30 minutes we no
longer see trim 33 at sites of dna
breaks
and so
to determine which domains of trem 33
may contribute its localization to these
types of dna breaks
we treated hela cells
with
the flag tag constructs encoding either
the wild type trim 33 or the series of
mutant constructs including the ring
domain mutants trim 33 ca
the trim 33 phd
domain mutant and the trim 33 bromo
domain mutants as well
as the atpase zed mutant
what we observed was that the trim 33ca
mutant
in previous reports has been shown to
lack ubiquitin ligase activity and
previous reports have also indicated
that the trim 33 phd triple a mutant
has been shown to not bind methylated
histone residues
and so we subjected these hela cells to
uv laser damage and trim 33 localization
was monitored by immunofluorescence
and what we can see is that wild type
trim 33 and the trim 33 ca mutants both
localized rapidly to site of dna breaks
in contrast the deletion of either the
phd domain or the bromo domain abrogated
trim 33's localization to the site of
these laser damage
the trim 33 phd with the atpase mutant
form also greatly reduced the
localization of dna breaks as we can see
here
and so what this told us was that the
chromatin binding phd and bromodomains
are critical for the robust localization
of tremcharity3 to sites of dna breaks
furthermore
to investigate the potential role of
trem33 and the dna damage response
our lab examined the effects of
depleting trim 33 on the sensitivity of
cells to dna damaging agents
and so hela cells were transfected with
either an sh or si rna with two
different trim 33 sh rna
or one trim 33 si rna
and after 48 hours
the cells were treated with different
concentrations of bleomycin which is a
dna damaging agent
and the introduction and so we observe
the dynamics of cell survival with the
introduction of these shrnas and what we
can see is that with the control sh rna
that
the cells were still able to survive
with increasing concentrations of
theomyosin treatment
however
those cells that were treated with the
trim 33 mutants
showed
increased sensitivity to the biomycin
treatment
furthermore
in this panel what we can see is that
the introduction of an shrna resistance
wild type trim 33 could rescue that
gliomyosin sensitivity of trim 33
depletion
and this can be seen here if we look at
the blue line this is showing our
control sh rna
our pink line is just celsius with
trim 33 sh rna only
with the introduction of the trim 33
wild type vector this was able to rescue
the cell survival and desensitize it to
the biomyson treatment
indicating to us that trim charity 3
plays a role in the dna damage response
further we wanted to investigate which
dna repair protein was involved in
recruiting trim to sites of dna breaks
and was regulating its localization at
these sites
and so in these set of experiments trim
33 localization the sites of dna breaks
was evaluated with inhibiting three
important dna repair proteins including
atm
atr and dna pk
and in these set of experiments they
showed us that when we treated cells
with an acm inhibitor we could still see
the recruitment of trim-33 at the site
of dna breaks
when an acr
mutant was introduced in these cells we
were still able to see the recruitment
and localization
of trim 33 at sites of dna breaks
furthermore
dna pk deficient cells labeled
m059j was unaffected
and we can still see the recruitment of
trim 33 at the site of dna breaks so
this told us that trimmed 3 is not
dependent on acm
atr or dnapk
now given that car formation is required
for the recruitment of some dna repair
proteins including out one that was
shown earlier our lab wanted to examine
the role of par
in the recruitment of trim33 at sites of
dna breaks
and so what we see in this panel is that
when our cells were treated with a part
inhibitor we first could not see any
formation of par compared to the control
further
in looking at the localization of trim
33 to sites of dna breaks and these
cells that are treated with the parp
inhibitor we could not see the
localization and recruitment of trimming
33 at sites of dna breaks and we know
that dna damage occurred because we
could visualize phosphoh2oax and so this
set of experiments helped to tell us
that trim 33
is localized the size of dna breaks in a
part-dependent manner
furthermore the recruitment of trim33 to
uv laser scissors and juice damage was
also greatly reduced and tarp deficient
mouse embryonic fibroblasts when
compared with park wild type mouse
embryonic fibroblasts as we can see here
and so furthermore
we know that the dna repair proteins
apls and alk1 are recruited to sites of
dna damage in a carb dependent manner
and so
we our lab was interested in
investigating
which regions of alp1
may be required for trim-33 localization
to dna breaks
if indeed they may interact and so
cells fatally expressing an alk1
sh or short hairpin was reconstituted
with a wild type alph one
we also treated cells with an alk1
k77r mutant which is the atpase dead
form of alp1
we also treated these cells with an
alpha 1d7 z723a macro domain mutant
which is unable to interact with par and
fails to localize dna breaks
we then subjected these cells to uv
laser induced breaks and trim 33
localization was observed using
immunofluorescence against bodies
against antibodies of trim 33
and so in this first panel we can see
that with the control shrna we are able
to visualize trim 33
and those cells that are treated with an
alpha and sh there is reduced
accumulation of trimaturity 3 at size of
dna breaks
now when the cells were reconstituted
with a well-type alk1 this was able to
rescue the activity and localization of
trim 33 x type of dna breaks as we can
see here
in the kinase dead or the atpase dead
mutant form of alp1 treated cells we
were still able to see trim charity
recruited to the site of dna breaks
however when the par binding mutant form
of alk1 was treated we could not see the
recruitment or localizations of trim23
at the site of dna breaks
and what this told us was that
the par binding activity of alk1
but not its catalytic activity is
required for its function in localizing
trim
33 to the size of dna breaks
and so furthermore
we wanted to determine whether the dna
damage induced interaction of alp1 and
trim33
is dependent on par synthesis
and so
we were what our lab did was perform
whole immunoprecipitation
experiments and dna treated nuclear
extracts
of hela cells
and so these hela cells were either mock
treated
or treated with a parp inhibitor and
then exposed to zero gray
10
grays of
ionizing radiation
or 100 joules of uv light
these treatments were specifically
chosen because our lab recognized that
they would allow us
to follow the dynamics of interaction
after an acute episode of dna damage
now
although the interaction of alk1 and
trim33 was not detected in untreated
cells
what was observed was a robust
interaction five minutes after both
ionizing radiation and uv light
treatment with trim 33 and alpha
and this was partially diminished after
10 minutes as we can see for both
ionizing radiation
and the uv light treatment
furthermore the interaction of trim23
and alk1 after ionizing radiation and uv
light treatment was significantly
reduced in cells that were treated with
a parp inhibitor as we can see on the
right panel side here
and so this suggested to us that trim
charity 3 and alpha 1 interact in
response to dna damage and that it is
partly dependent on active car synthesis
at these sites of dna damage
to determine now whether the par binding
activity of alk1 or its atpase activity
is required for its interaction with
trim33
cells were transfected with a flag tag
constructs encoding either
wow type alpha
the hcpa's dead mutant form of out one
label
k77r
or
the macro domain mutant labeled d723a
and this one cannot bind to par
and the cells were subjected to uv
damage the cell extracts were collected
after five minutes post dna damage
and
immunoprecipitated with anti-flag b
and processed for western blot analysis
which we see here
and they were processed against
antibodies for trimmed 3.
and what we observed was that both the
wild type l1 and alphon k-77r mutants
interacted with trim 33 after
uv damage
however what was observed was that the
macro domain mutant
d723a
which does not localize the dna breaks
failed to interact with trim283
and so further
to determine now whether the par binding
of alk1 is sufficient enough to in
interact with trim 33 a powerbombed alk1
immobilized on nitrocellulose was
incubated with purified trim-33
and after washing it was analyzed with
immunoblotting with antibodies to trim
33.
what was observed was that there was no
interaction of tar bond alph one with
trim 33 using this approach
and so these experiments suggested to
our lab that the par binding of alkaline
is not
by itself sufficient to induce the
interaction of alp1 with trim 33 and
vitru
next our lab was interested in
investigating the effects of trim 33 on
the dynamics of alp1 recruitment to
sites of dna damage
and so
our lab depleted
trim23 by shrna in hela cells and then
these cells
were treated with an sh rna and we
noticed that alk1 was rapidly recruited
to sites of laser scissors induced
damage
but it was not detectable at these sites
45 minutes pose damage
in contrast what was observed was that
treatment of cells with the trim23 sh
rna resulted in prolonged retention of
alp1
at the site of laser scissors damage and
elf one could even be seen 45 minutes
after treatment and this was consistent
with prior reports that had indicated
that alk1 is also accompanied by the
prolonged retention of
xrcc1 which is another important dna
repair protein at sites of dna damage
so
to examine the impact of trim 33 on
alph-1 recruitment
at sites of dna damage
our lab complemented trim-33 knockdown
cells with an sh rna resistance while
typecrim33
and
the ring domain mutant trim 33c8
importantly to note was that the
prolonged retention of alk1 at damaged
sites observed and the trim 33 knocked
down cells as we saw in the first set of
experiments was corrected by the
introduction of the shrna resistance
while type trim 33 construct
however
this was not corrected by the trim 33 ca
ring domain mutant
and so
what this told us was that trim 33 is
required for the timely dissociation of
alk1 from the site of dna damage and
that this function requires an intact
ring domains
furthermore
we wanted to see our and determine
whether alt1 over expression leads to
similar effects
furthermore in investigating the dynamic
of alk-1's recruitment and association
at dna breaks
in relation to trim 33 what we observed
was that trim23 33 knockdown has no
effects on the dynamics of par at the uv
laser induced dna breaks
and in these set of experiments
in both control and trim 33 knocked down
cells
car rapidly localized the dna breaks at
5 minutes
but it was not present at these breaks
post 45 minutes
suggesting to us that in the absence of
trim 33 alph 1 remains at these breaks
even when par is no longer present
and so collectively these experiments
suggested that trim 33 is required for
the timely dissociation of alk1 from the
site of dna and that this function
requires also an intact ring domain from
the previous experiment i showed
furthermore
we know now that alkaline dissociation
is delayed in trim 33 depleted cells
and so now our lab wanted to determine
whether the overexpression of alkaline
would lead to a similar effect
and so they evaluated the dynamic of
alkaline overexpression on its
localization to uv laser scissors in
juice breaks now cells overexpressing
well type alpha 1 labeled slp and alk1
here
show the prolonged retention of alk1 at
sites of dna breaks
now the overexpression of wild-type
trim-33 was able to restore this album
dynamics and alp1 can no longer be
detected
at sites of dna breaks after 45 minutes
with the introduction of wild-type trims
and so the over-expression of wild-type
trim was able to restore elf one's
dynamics suggesting that the proper
stoichiometry between trim 33 and alpha
1
is indeed essential for the timely
dissociation of alp1 from sites of dna
breaks
now
alk1 has been shown and is known to be
amplified and over expressed in certain
cancers suggesting that it can be
functioning as an oncogene
and so our data raised the possibility
that relative levels of alk1 and trim33
may be important for the regulations of
out one activity
and so to directly investigate the
effects of trim23 expression on the
phenotype associated with alkaline over
expressions
cells that were stably over expressing
either an empty vector
labeled
flp
flp
in flag or wow type alph one were
analyzed for sensitivity to bleomycin
and shown here
is the result of the experiment showing
that the over expression of wild-type
trem 33 greatly reduces the sensitivity
of alkaline over-expression of cell
sibling myosin with these cells showing
similar sensitivity as the vector
expressing cells
however the overexpression of the ring
domain mutant trim character 3 ca
failed to rescue the gliomyosin
sensitivity of alkaline overexpressing
cells
and so the effects of trim23
overexpression on the induction of dna
breaks
is consistent with reports that suggest
outpoint expression promotes chromatin
relaxation and
but it's still being there the increased
overexpression increases the
accessibility
of the dna damaging agent leomycin
the over-expression of the wild-type
trim-33
but not the
trim23ca mutants was able to counteract
the effects of this alk-1 over
expressions
after the induction of dna damage
and so
cells that were over expressing trimmed
alkaline were able to then be reduced in
expression after the introduction of
wild type trim 33
and this is consistent with prior
results shown previously in the
presentation indicating that elevated
trim 33 expression can counteract the
phenotype of alkaline overexpression
and that this requires an intact
ring domain because the ring by the ring
mutant domain is not able to rescue this
expression
and so together
these experiments help to
create this model for the interaction of
trem3 and out one in dna repair and so
we know that with the induction of dna
damage we have the activation of parp
that is at the site of dna breaks
with the formation of par chains or part
synthesis
the recruitment of important proteins
like alph-1 comes in and relaxes the
chromatin
now trim turret 3 comes in and
presumably performs its function
as a ubiquitin ligase and ubiquitinates
alk1 possibly removing it from the sites
of dna breaks and as we have shown in
these experiments trim charity 3
knockdown confers dna damage sensitivity
in cells and it delays dissociation of
alkaline
and given that these proteins
are
interacting and are a part of the dna
damage response
they can also serve
as
targeted proteins for treatment in
different types of cancers where they
are overexpressed
and so
i would like to now thank
my lab members and my last supervisor dr
sridhar genisen
for all of his help in helping to train
me with these different techniques and
to perform experiments similar to this
that was discussed today
also this project was spearheaded by a
tool cool cranny who i work under direct
supervision with in the lab as well and
also our other lab members who are all
instrumental in helping to perform these
experiments
and at this time i will take any
questions from the audience thank you so
much for listening
thank you rukia for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q and a
portion of the webinar if you have a
question you would like to ask please do
so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
let's get started our first question is
do you know if trim 33 is implicated in
any kind of health diseases and what
type of cancer
yes so
from previous studies we do know that
the loss of trim 33 cooperates with
k-rest activation and this induces a lot
of cystic tumors
and adenocarcinomas of the pancreas and
also
trim 33 has been implicated in a lot of
blood cancers such as
b cell
and acute pro male
leukemia also be all and cmml
and so we do know that trim23 has been
implicated in these specific types of
cancers um there has been data showing
that it's
also implicated in certain thyroid
cancers where it forms fusions with
other proteins that drives the
progression of that cancer
so yes
those are a few of the diseases that
it's implicated in
thank you rupiah our next question here
is
are there any drugs on the market that
potentially targets trim 33
on the market right now i know that
there is currently a clinical trial
looking at bromo domain inhibitors to
see if that is effective as in the
presentation i noted that trim 33 has a
bromo domain and so hopefully through
this clinical trial
it's successful and we can then start
treating patients that might have the
trim proteins implicated in their
cancers with this bromodomain inhibitor
hopefully
thank you again rupia we have one more
question here
do we know exactly how trim 33 removes
alc1 from sites of dna breaks and during
repair
well what we do know is that trim turret
is the reason e3 ubiquitin ligase and so
it marks proteins for degradation and
currently in the lab doctor tool kokone
is investigating this so hopefully this
data will be published soon and we'll be
able to know the mechanisms of that
thank you again rupia for your time
today and for your important research we
would also like to thank labyrinths and
our sponsor gibco by thermo fisher
scientific for underwriting today's
educational webcast before we go i'd
like to thank the audience for joining
us today and for their interesting
questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
lab roots will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
until next time
goodbye